un momento para la información económica
en france 24 me acompaña en nuestro
estudio nuestro compañero jorge hurtado
jorge bienvenido vamos a comenzar
hablando de argentina y de los índices
de precios al consumo porque alcanzaron
niveles históricos así es la inflación
de marzo allí se aceleró a niveles
históricos presionada principalmente por
el contexto internacional la inflación
interanual de argentina o sea el dato de
marzo de 2021 frente a marzo de 2022 se
ubicó en 50 y 5,1 por ciento el dato
pone argentina entre los países de más
alta inflación del mundo en américa
latina sólo está por detrás de venezuela
la inflación crónica que vive argentina
no parece dar tregua pese a las medidas
del gobierno que le declaró la guerra a
la subida de los precios del gobierno
alberto fernández enfrenta además del
descontento social por la el alza de los
precios unas metas respecto a la
inflación acordada con el fondo
monetario internacional veamos el
siguiente informe que preparó dennis
herrera
la inflación no da respiro a los
argentinos quienes buscan un sinfín de
caminos para enfrentarlo como esta
albañil quien ya no puede sobrevivir con
su sueldo
plata degenerada hoy en día
la verdad que está muy caro no rindes y
yo me llevo enferma no sé quién le va a
dar de comer a mi familia al tiempo el
encarecimiento de la vida en argentina
ha provocado que el descontento social
se agudiza la inflación lo que nos
empuja a hacer esta clase de venta de
salir de nuestro hábitat laboral estamos
más cómodos no nos queda otra vez es que
tenés dos o hasta tres trabajos con
mucha suerte y ni siquiera así llegar a
fin de mes porque un día un producto
está un precio al otro ya está otro
precio y eso no no mata no sólo hago a
lo que estamos acá sino a lo que estaba
a lo largo ya lo ancho del país la
pandemia y la guerra nuclear han sido
dos de los últimos hechos que han
agravado la inflación en argentina el
gobierno implementado medidas que
intentaban batallar esta epidemia en el
país del cono sur como la creación de un
fideicomiso para estabilizar el precio
del trigo un aumento de subsidios de los
alimentos para personas más vulnerables
y la apertura de negociaciones
salariales entre los sindicatos y los
patronales pero la más polémica de esta
propuesta es la refinanciación de la
deuda con el fondo monetario
internacional las proyecciones
internacionales como la del bancoestado
y morgan estima que cierra el año con
una inflación interanual del 62 por
ciento lo que significa un gran impacto
pero los argentinos donde el 40% de la
población vive en la pobreza cuando
ahora vamos a analizar en estos
incrementos de mes a mes o sea de
febrero a marzo allí el rubro de
educación aumentó en marzo 23% respecto
a febrero seguido de la ropa así como la
vivienda el costo de la electricidad de
los servicios básicos como el agua y los
combustibles entre los alimentos que más
aumentaron está el precio de los huevos
el pollo el pan y el café cifradas nada
alentadoras pero la inflación es un
fenómeno global y también hay alza de
precios en el reino unido- ahí la
inflación interanual se ubicó en 7 por
ciento en marzo motivado por el
incremento de los precios de la
electricidad y el gas así como el
transporte y los precios de los
materiales que usa el sector industrial
que provocaron este aumento de hecho es
el más alto en 30 años en busca de
contener la inflación el banco de
inglaterra subió el mes pasado a los
tipos de interés
5% al 0.75 este sería el tercer
incremento consecutivo los expertos no
descartan otro aumento de los tipos de
interés porque la inflación está muy por
encima del objetivo del banco central
que era del 2% fijado para este año en
ese país dejamos la inflación por un
lado porque eeuu hizo un llamado a china
que se sume a las sanciones contra rusia
específicamente lo hizo janet yellen
quien es secretaria del tesoro
estadounidense advirtió a china de que
su falta de participación en las
sanciones de occidente contra rusia
podría afectar la voluntad de los países
de trabajar con beijing la funcionaria
pidió a china que ayude a poner fin a la
guerra escuchemos
james en spray de james
sean cuales sean los objetivos y las
estrategias geopolíticas de china no
vemos ninguna interpretación benigna de
la invasión de rusia ni de sus
consecuencias para el orden
internacional china no puede esperar que
la comunidad mundial respete sus
llamamientos a los principios de
soberanía e integridad territorial en el
futuro si no respeta esos principios
ahora cuando es necesario china ha
firmado recientemente una relación
especial con rusia espero fervientemente
que china saque algo positivo de esta
relación y ayude a poner fin a esta
guerra
lo que vamos a ver ahora son los
indicadores económicos así es empezamos
con wall street' que rebotó por los
resultados empresariales en eeuu y las
últimas cifras de la inflación mientras
si revisamos el dato en europa la bolsa
española cerró con un alza del 0 46 por
ciento gracias al apoyo de wall street y
en américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
cerró en positivo animada por las
empresas estatales y pendientes también
de la renovación del consejo
administrativo de la petrolera petrobras
buena jornada en américa la tiene a
jorge hurtado muchísimas gracias con la
información económica gracias también
ustedes
en la pantalla de france 24
[Música]